[Musica]
immaginate un artista all'apice della
sua carriera è un collezionista che più
di ogni cosa desidera avere un suo
ritratto
siamo negli anni 80 e vi vorrei
raccontare oggi la storia di un'opera
avvolta nel mistero
un'opera di cui abbiamo perso i colori
dico abbiamo perso le misure abbiamo
perso la storia ma non abbiamo perso il
titolo
l'artista di cui sto parlando oggi a
gino de dominicis e aveva già realizzato
all'epoca diverse opere come questa per
esempio una performance il cui titolare
abbastanza autoesplicativo tentativo di
far formare dei quadrati invece che dei
cerchi attorno a un sasso che cade
nell'acqua
oppure quest altra opera perché aveva
richiesto un trasformatore ufficiale una
cassa infatti l'opera era molto
ingombrante era complicatissimo da
spostare
si trattava infatti di un cubo il titolo
un cubo invisibile il tempo passava il
collezionista esigeva la sua opera
gino voglio avere il mio ritratto e così
de dominicis non soddisfa e presentò
questo un puntino su uno sfondo
monocromatico il collezionista ra basito
come voi oggi non capiva dove va il mio
ritratto dove sono non riesco a
ritrovarmi fu il titolo a risolvere la
questione ritratto di collezionista
visto da dieci chilometri di distanza
quest'opera di giorgione è conservato
alla galleria dell'accademia di venezia
è stata realizzata nel primo decennio
del 1500 e non abbiamo dei dubbi sul
titolo la didascalia è molto chiara
precisa rettangolare la tempesta
in realtà questo titolo nè originario di
giorgione infatti vedremo come il titolo
è un concetto moderno non è sempre
esistito come noi lo diamo per scontato
un po come forse ti chiami marco giulia
claudio francesca
in realtà questo titolo deriva da un
inventario e in particolare
da una descrizione che si fa marcantonio
michiel gabriele vendramin che vede
l'opera nella collezione di marcantonio
michiel titolo paesetto in tela con la
tempesta quella cingano il soldato fu
demand esordi del castelfranco da questa
descrizione non sembra che sapessero che
cosa fosse il vero soggetto infatti a
un'opera misteriosa erano passati pochi
decenni dalla realizzazione
tuttavia la storia cambia semplificare e
ha fatto sì che il titolo fosse la
tempesta sono qui oggi per parlarvi dei
titoli delle opere d'arte è più che
altro del senza titolo perché perché la
realtà è che siamo avvolti dai titoli
siamo soffocati soli dei films dei
quotidiani e delle riviste e tre le
canzoni degli album i titoli dei ted
oppure il mio titolo che ha senza titolo
vediamo nel mondo di titoli come i
nostri stessi nomi in qualche modo
questi dlc soffocano e per pensarci
basta ricordare un incubo che ebbe
l'artista del minimalismo e robert
morris che contestava anche lo stesso
minimalismo e una notte si sveglia
bruscamente e inizia a riflettere su
quanto gli scali non fossero innocenti
sono delle granate di parole dei
farfugli borbottanti che schiacciano
l'immaginazione
il titolo non è sempre esistito come
dicevo infatti il passato il committente
affidava ad un artista la realizzazione
di un'opera e questo lo realizzava la
scolpiva spesso con l'aiuto di umanisti
e letterati quindi titolo in qualche
modo non esisteva inoltre le opere molto
spesso erano trasparenti nel senso che
il soggetto era chiaramente visibile
vediamo qui una madonna col bambino san
pietro e paolo san giovanni battista
oppure anche i santi patroni locali come
santa lucia e san giorgio e il drago le
opere rimanevano un contesto culturale
specifico riconoscibile chiaramente
influenzato dall'ambiente che lo
circonda va bene raro che queste opere
si muovessero è la democratizzazione
dell'arte la nascita delle accademie la
nascita delle mostre lo sviluppo del
mercato
l'alfabetizzazione la stampa che fa sì
che le opere abbiano qualcosa che tutti
voi avete oggi un passaporto una carta
identità una maniera per potersi
spostare nel tempo per la trasmissione
da padre in figlio e nel luogo per
potersi muovere nello spazio per poter
attraversare le frontiere e così le
opere iniziano piano piano ad assumere
dei titoli sono una storica dell'arte e
ho sempre amato la libertà delle
immagini e mi sono chiesta come il
titolo potesse influenzare così tanto la
percezione un'opera poi faremo un
esperimento insieme ma una volta eletto
un titolo è finita non riusciamo più a
vedere ciò che avevamo immaginato prima
siamo schiacciati siamo oppressi siamo
condizionati semplicemente tuttavia ci
sono artisti che coi titoli hanno
giocato molto
guardate quest opera del pittore william
turner prendo fiato perché il titolo è
spaventosa tempesta di neve battello a
vapore al largo della bocca di un porto
che fa segnali no che poco profonde
passa il comando l'autore era in questa
tempesta nella notte che l'aria lascia
harwich è tutto un titolo i livelli a
cui sono arrivati i titoli poi è stato
incredibile diciamo diceva che era un
altro colore della tavolozza un elemento
fondamentale costituente l'opera d'arte
e ci sono poi artisti come per esempio
tanti artisti al surrealismo che hanno
giocato molto con i titoli come in
questo caso mirò di rete semplicemente
un'opera astratta e invece si tratta di
una donna sulla riva del lago resa
iridescente dal passato di un cigno
oppure quanti di voi in questa altra
opera riuscirebbero a vedere delle
figure nella notte guidate dalle tracce
fosforescenti del
lumache ma mirò poi ha avuto dei
ripensamenti e ho scritto una lettera al
suo gallerista pierre matisse il terzo
genito del pittore henri matisse scrisse
il 12 ottobre del 1934
caro pier ho pensato molto alla
questione dei titoli e devo confessare
che non riesco a trovare nessuno che non
sia arbitrario
in passato ho dato dei titoli i miei
lavori e che titoli abbiamo visto ma mi
sono sempre sembrati uno scherzo ti do
il permesso di dare dei titoli con la
condizione che non evochino questo è
qualcosa che voglio evitare
completamente composizione per esempio i
titoli letterari entrati in maniera
surrealista i titoli quindi
costituiscono un problema anche per gli
artisti cercano di devono essere
identificate le opere d'arte ma come se
la parola i nomi giulio condiziona così
tanto la vostra percezione vi ricorda un
giulio che avete conosciuto per esempio
quest'opera è del pittore americano che
lavorò soprattutto in inghilterra
james abbott mcneill whistler è il 1872
quando presenta quest opera alla royal
academy di londra il titolo composizione
in grigio e nero numero 1 intendeva
l'opera come una composizione cromatica
non voleva che vedessimo un soggetto
viene forzato a dare un titolo ea
specificare che le si tratta del
ritratto della madre di whistler è
irritato il nome dell'artista è furioso
si chiede e si chiede perché gli inglesi
e forse intendeva tutto il pubblico e
non riesco a percepire un opera come
un'opera d'arte e si interessano
soprattutto alla storia attenzione che
si suppone un opera possa raccontare che
si suppone un opera possa raccontare un
immagine ma
lasciamo l'europa alla vecchia europa e
andiamo in america negli stati uniti
dove negli anni 40 nei primissimi anni
40 nasce l'espressionismo astratto
questa opera di jackson pollock il
titolo senza titolo
attenzione non sa non è che non ha dato
il titolo ha scelto intitolarla senza
titolo obbligato a dare un titolo ha
scelto il senza titolo capite l'impatto
e la forza di un gesto così importante
senza precedenti che è confusione come
indicarlo pensate una biblioteca in cui
tutti i volumi sono senza titolo come
ordinarne uno come parlarne come
descriverlo come citarlo eppure pollo
che ha scelto senza titolo ma questa
scelta non è stata fortunata non è stata
apprezzata sicuramente dalla critica e
infatti pochi anni dopo espone
quest'opera numero 30 l'iphone e per
diversi anni dal 1951 al 1952 53 e
successivamente quando viene esposta nel
1955 alla galleria sydney a nice
il titolo a ritmo autunnale aveva
individuato i numeri come una soluzione
per poter non influenzare lo spettatore
tuttavia creavano confusione immaginate
il numero 30 hanno un grado di ci si
creava e così nasce un ritmo autunnale
ma sono altri i pittori che hanno
vissuto più in profondità anche la
durezza e la le conseguenza di un senza
titolo
in particolare la loro storia si
intreccia con questa donna la mecenate
dell'arte
la signora peggy guggenheim il 1946
quando invita acli forst il pittore
americano a tenere una personale alla
galleria art this entry a new york
organizza la mostra ci sono gli inviti
tutto quanto è poco prima
dell'inaugurazione lei andré breton
vanno a visualizzare le opere con seal
presente sono tantissime opere le
apprezzano molto ma i titoli o no le
opere sono tutte senza titolo
i due sono furiosi come perdere un'opera
d'arte come raccontarla questo senza
titolo crea confusione e così grazie
alle ricerche anche del professor david
dan pham siamo riusciti a ricostruire
tutte le opere esposte
i due hanno obbligato vincolato
schiacciato steel l'anno forzato a
mettere dei titoli alle opere d'arte e
sono dei titoli pressanti elegia
premonizione autoritratto gatto siamese
figlie sono dei titoli molto impattanti
vogliamo fare un esperimento
guardate quest opera esposta in questa
mostra originariamente senza titolo una
composizione o come qualsiasi cosa voi
vorreste quest'opera sia invece no
perché peggy guggenheim e andré breton
hanno dato questo titolo lo spettro e il
pappagallo
non so quanti di voi ora riuscire a
prevedere qualcosa diverso sulla
sinistra un pappagallo chiaramente nella
forma e se rivedrete quest'opera ci
vedere sempre un pappagallo riuscirete a
vedere
nient'altro
mark rocco inizia a dare dei titoli
abbastanza riconoscibile sicuramente
tradizionali troviamo infatti figura
donna paesaggio scena metropolitana e
così via
sentito li riconoscibili permettono di
acquisire delle opere di parlarne di
citarne a permettono all'artista di
avere delle recensioni importanti e dal
1946 che lui si spinge verso
l'astrazione contesterà anche il termine
astrazione tuttavia come se queste
figure si espandessero su dei cani
monocromatici dissolvessero piano piano
e seguono le parole e così anche mark
rothko anche lui negli anni 40 inizia a
non dare i titoli alle opere d'arte
senza titolo
tuttavia come nel caso di pollock è
costretto
ha cercato di individuare queste opere
quindi utilizzo dei numeri però vince su
tutti rocco perché perché cambia i
numeri continuamente a una stessa opera
da diversi numeri
via via che la espone a una confusione
totale non si capisce più niente la
ricostruzione del catalogo di rothko è
stata infatti complicatissima perché le
opere cambiavano il titolo via via che
erano esposte cambiavano anche
l'orientamento delle stesse immaginate
la confusione e la bellezza di un just
del genere che conta sa ciò che abbiamo
sempre creduto cioè che con l'erudizione
con lo studio un giorno saremo riusciti
avvicinarsi alle opere d'arte
invece è proprio il contrario una danza
movimento un corteggiamento una dedica
d'amore una dedizione
infatti questo è l'unico modo per poter
fare l'esperienza delle opere d'arte
poter abbracciare in qualche modo e non
catalogare definire precisamente
tuttavia anche questi numeri creano
moltissima confusione e così quando
anche lui inizia a lavorare con un
gallerista iniziano i titoli i colori
come titoli
ecco che vediamo bianco rosso giallo
rothko è furioso perché i titoli
sembrano diventati colori sembra
diventata il soggetto ma non è
assolutamente così infatti scriverà
precisamente che non sono i colori il
soggetto dell'opera non è neanche una
composizione astratta semplicemente non
è ciò che ciascuno di voi oggi vuole
vedere in quest'opera ci sono asserviti
centinaia di migliaia di titoli perché
potessimo arrivare al senza titolo
immaginate la potenza di un gesto del
genere senza precedenti addirittura
steel il pittore di cui vi ho parlato
prima cancellerà retroattivamente tutti
i suoi titoli e inventerà un numero
progressivo di inventario per poterli
citare per poterne parlare un'operazione
che nessuno aveva mai fatto prima ma se
ancora non vi ho convinto
dell'importanza del senza titolo di
sottrarci invece che riempirci di parole
allora pensiamo a ulisse che quando
riuscì ad accecare polifemo
poi disse di chiamarsi nessuno e così
quando gli altri ciclopi e lo soccorsero
chi ti ha accecato che dobbiamo cercare
e lui rispose nessuno senza titolo e che
solo così ebbe salva la vita perché non
riuscirono a trovare
e se ancora non vi ha convinto
guardate quest opera dell'artista carlo
benvenuto uno specchio che ha invitato a
guardarci e per una volta sottrarci a
non chiamarci a fare un passo indietro a
guardare senza esprimere l'opinione
semplicemente sentire ma se questo è un
gesto troppo radicale perché ciascuno di
noi poi ha un nome e un economia si deve
muovere si deve spostare avere una vita
dobbiamo riconoscerci in qualche modo
allora vi inviterei a tornare alla
tempesta di giorgione è in realtà una
fotografia di un artista contemporaneo e
non l'ha chiamata tempesta non l'ha
chiamata senza titolo ma semplicemente
deciso di not yet titled grazie
[Applauso]